[Music]
what do we do consequences of worst case
Inari I don't
[Music]
something like decriminalization is
happening in most of the rich world now
if not officially then unofficially and
it's worth just making clear when we
talk about decriminalization that's a
different thing from legalization
decriminalization means that something
is still banned it's still illegal but
it's no longer a criminal offense and
then the other stuff that's interesting
and I think probably more radical still
is the legalization that we're seeing in
cannabis and this is happening in so far
four states at the us-canada is going to
do it Uruguay is doing it Jamaica has
said it will do it too
governments are desperate for revenue
you know we are public services around a
lot of strain the milk cow of the
banking sector isn't producing as much
milk so we need new sources of revenue
and you know taxing decriminalize drugs
or they'd have to be legalized to be
taxed would provide a genuine attraction
for government and then we said with
money going into criminals they're big
that'd be going to you and this is an
important difference because with
decriminalization you make things easier
for users but the supply side of the
business ie the dealing is still illegal
so if you go to Portugal and buy cocaine
you'll be fine you know you won't be
arrested you won't go to prison but the
cocaine that you've spent your euros on
it still comes from the same cartels in
Mexico and elsewhere that make their
money cutting off people's heads and the
important thing about legalization is
that you bring the whole business into
the legal world and in if you go to
Colorado and buy a joint there the
cannabis has been grown by taxpaying
law-abiding people
if you really opened up the whole system
just treated it like any other commodity
maybe a taxed commodity like cigarettes
and alcohol
what would the effects be I think what
one of the effects at least initially
would be quite uncomfortable because
once you eliminate the smugglers and the
cartels
it's then much easier for people to
export freely so be more stuff coming in
drive down the street price people would
consume more because it would be cheaper
and it would be less fraught with police
hazards so you would get more people
into drugs initially cannabis drinks
they do now they can do cannabis
everything you can imagine that
appealing to you know new audiences you
can imagine it a large kind of big big
marijuana emerging in the way that we
currently have big tobacco
so the idea is that you make drugs you
have a Cana mist of scale they're
cheaper they're safer and then also you
out-compete the drug gangs and do they
just go into cybercrime or something
else instead what evidence do we have
the question you raised about the moving
into other types of crime is a
legitimate one and there's evidence
already that farmers in the Sierra Madre
who used to grow cannabis and our
growing opium poppies which is not a
terribly good news and we see this quite
a lot you know in Britain in the 1990s
car theft went down quite dramatically
because it became a lot harder to steal
cars and at the same time not
coincidentally we saw an increase in a
number of robberies of young people if
you look at the Sinaloa cartel they're
really suffering there because of course
in the states if you if you go to one of
the places where they make the legal
stuff it's so much more sophisticated I
mean I went round the Chocolate Factory
in Colorado where they were making
marijuana edibles and it's just
extraordinary it's like a cross between
kind of Willy Wonka and Walter White you
know the Fed and the Sinaloa cartel
doesn't do chocolate brownies you know
they can't compete on this stuff
you